house marking Dennis B he was on drugs
very mom okay here we go
Ramona Singer saying something she
shouldn't have on the Real Housewives of
New York City even I going through the
show and I go oh I don't remember doing
that it's just always really wild to see
a tree playback such a lame statement
and unfeeling towards our friend
Bethenny who just lost her best friend I
can't do this
alcohol excuses a lot but not that
statement sorry Coco you can't come out
I don't talk about Dennis I want to do
honor him and his memory it's not talk
about him the reality star was
referencing co-star Bethenny Frankel's
late boyfriend at Denis Shields who died
unexpectedly in August 2018 authorities
initially suspected Denis died of some
sort of overdose but the New York
medical examiner ultimately listed his
cause of death as undetermined boat and
then did he do something cause he was in
pain but it doesn't matter he's dead
before the latest episode aired
Ramona posted to Instagram to address
her flippant remark writing I cringed
when I saw what I said about Denis in
tonight's episode
it definitely wasn't one of my finer
moments she added I respected and liked
him very much and I sincerely apologized
to his family and Bethenny for my
thoughtless comments now while Ramona
might not have been there for Bethenny
in the moment you know I'm there for
Bethenny and she's been there for me in
a big way co-star LuAnn de Lesseps tells
et the rest of the group rallied around
there pal as she dealt with the loss you
know when you have traumatic things like
that happened in your life you know
girlfriend support you and that's you
know that's what you're gonna see you're
gonna see support and then you're gonna
see whatever is going to unfold as usual
housewives
[Music]